[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais bien qu'on regarde ensemble
cette image et qu'on imagine que la
tâche blanche ici représente l'ensemble
de mes connaissances
tout ce que je sais et que du coup le
noir tout le reste représente mon
ignorance
en général quand on commence à
s'intéresser à un nouveau sujet quand on
creuse un sujet donc mon sujet pendant
dix ans et est le cerveau les
neurosciences on a l'impression que
notre cercle de connaissances va
s'élargir que plus on va creuser notre
sujet plus on va comprendre en fait de
quoi il s'agit et en fait moi est
quelque chose de complètement contre
intuitif kim qui m'est arrivé plus je
creuse et mon sujet plus je comprenais
le cerveau plus en fait mon cercle de
connaissances se rétrécit c est en fait
avec le recul je me rends compte que
c'est pas que mes connaissances
rétrécissait c'est juste que je prenais
beaucoup plus conscience de tout ce que
je ne savais pas sur le sujet plus je
prenais plus je me rendais compte que
c'était vraiment en fait très compliqué
et que je ne savais pas autant que je
pensais savoir et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que pendant une période
j'étais vraiment je me sentais vraiment
experte je sentais que je savais tout
sur le cerveau que j'étais l'expert sur
le cerveau et donc cette période là où
cette phase c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'illusion de connaissances l'illusion
de connaissances c'est quoi c'est quand
on a trop confiance dans des
connaissances mais on se rend pas compte
qu'elles sont limitées
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler de
deux choses 2 pourquoi je pense que
l'illusion de connaissance est un des
plus grands dangers aujourd'hui dans une
société et j'aimerais aussi ouvrir une
parenthèse pour vous parler du cerveau
puisque c'était l'objet de mes
recherches et pour vous montrer que le
cerveau lui même à cette propension à
augmenter cette illusion en fait de
connaissances je vais vous le voulez
vous l'illustré donc le cerveau qui est
le fruit d'une très très longue
évolution on a tendance à oublier mais
le cerveau il a évolué pendant de très
très longues années 200 300 mille ans
dans un environnement assez hostile avec
des dangers imminents des prédateurs ou
nôtre
principal objectif était d'éviter les
dangers donc par exemple vous êtes dans
une forêt vous entendez un bruissement
dans les feuillages ça peut être du vent
ça peut être un prédateur et notre
cerveau avait comme objectif de faire
très rapidement des décisions qui
augmente nos chances de survie ces
raccourcis mentaux qui sont très rapides
qui sont très très utiles pour notre
fonctionnement de tous les jours
s'appelle des oris tic les auris tic
sont extrêmement inquiet c'est ce qui me
permet par exemple d'ouvrir une nouvelle
porte que jamais vu alors que c'est une
poignée nouvelles de descendre des
marches c'est extrêmement utile d'avoir
des eaux ristic mais des fois les auris
tic sont pas adaptées à leur contexte et
donc là on parle de biais cognitif pour
illustrer tout ça parce que ça peut
paraître un petit peu abstrait je vais
vous demander de regarder cette image et
je vais vous demander de comparer le
carré a ici au carré b qui est là
j'imagine que tout le monde dans cette
pièce voit le carré 1 comme étant d'un
gris plus foncé que le karibe est
parfait eh ben je vous assure que ces
deux carrés a et b sont exactement du
même niveau de gris c'est vraiment
exactement les mêmes c'est très
difficile d'avoir un même quand je vous
dis c'est ce qu'on appelle une illusion
non compressible c'est à dire que même
quand vous le savez vous avez du mal à
le voir il pas à les découper la faille
après la la présentation mais je vais
les isoler pour faciliter en fait
c'est très très dur de les voir vraiment
de différentes couleurs et donc là en
fait je vois leurs maîtres et vous allez
voir que même quand vous le savez le b
revient à être plus clair que le car est
là et donc c'est assez fascinant parce
que cette illusion d'optique montre à
quel point il ya des opérations mentales
très très rapide ces fameuses
heuristique qui opère dans le cerveau en
fait pour nous faire voir ce qui est le
plus probable
on a l'impression quand on regarde le
monde que l'on voit les choses
exactement comme elles sont mais en fait
on les voit telles qu'elles sont les
plus probables
et si ce qui se passe c'est que donc
déjà le quart et b il est dans le dans
l'ombre ici du plô vert or notre cerveau
c'est qu'en général les choses qui sont
dans l'ombre sont plus clair qu'elles
n'apparaissent donc déjà notre cerveau
va venir corriger pour cette ombre
vous avez peut-être déjà ressenti ça en
allant sur un escalator qui ne
fonctionnait pas et dès que vous montez
dessus vous êtes un peu en déséquilibre
parce que votre cerveau avait déjà
anticipé le mouvement et avait corrigé
ce mouvement donc toutes ces opérations
mentales qui sont très très utiles pour
notre survie de tous les jours donc les
eaux ristic
on voit ici qu'en fait elles peuvent
être trompeuses pour illustrer un peu
plus ce point je vais vous demander
maintenant de répondre à cette question
donc si je vous dis qu'un timbre et une
enveloppe coûte au total 1 euros et 10
centimes et que le timbre coûte 1 euro
de plus que l'enveloppent combien coûte
l'enveloppent c'est quoi la première
réponse qui vient votre esprit
la plupart des personnes je dirais même
tout le monde dans cette pièce à le 10
centimes qui apparaît à leurs esprits
automatiquement via une ristic ou un
raccourci et mentale bon il ya certains
qui vont se disent qu'il faut se dire
qu'il ya un piège ils vont calculer la
bonne réponse
la bonne réponse et 5 centimes parce
qu'un euro 5 + 5
ça fait 1 euro 10 et dans ce cas là le
timbre coûterait 1 euro de plus que
l'enveloppé
donc vous voyez que on a des réponses
automatiques dea on se dit mais c'est
évidemment ça c'est évidemment que le
carré à est plus foncée que le carré b
et on doute rarement en fait des
réponses toutes faites que notre cerveau
nous donne ça fait même l'objet de
beaucoup de recherches cette illusion en
fait de cette sueur confiance dans ce
nom ce que le cerveau l'audi et
illusion de connaissances au point que
des chercheurs sont allés faire des
exercices comme ça vous pouvez le tester
avec vos amis on a demandé à des gens de
dire s'il savait dessiné par exemple un
vélo s'il savait comme un vélo
fonctionner par des gens disent oui et
là pour leur demande d'aller vraiment
prendre un crayon un papier elle est
destinée le vélo les gens savent plus
ils savent plus où sont connectés
l'échelle si les pédales sont au milieu
au centre et c est en fait on on a tout
le temps cette sueur confiance on a des
réponses immédiates il par exemple je
vous demande si vous savez comment
fonctionne une fermeture éclair ou une
chasse d'eau on a l'impression que oui
mais s'il faut aller expliquer en détail
comment ça marche
c'est là qu'on se rend compte qu'en fait
on sait pas et c'est extrêmement
intéressant parce que ça montre que
quelque part ce notre cerveau et n'est
pas câblé pour avoir les bonnes réponses
on les plus fiables et pour aller vite
avoir des réponses approximatives
immédiate qui fonctionne à peu près et
qui font le job
ce qui est très très bien c'est
extrêmement utile pour nous sauf que ça
peut être dangereux si on n'en est pas
conscient si on n'est pas conscient que
ces raccourcis mentaux sont là et que
qu'elle nous donne tout le temps ses
illusions que ce soit des illusions
d'optique ou des illusions de
connaissances on se fait un peu trop
confiance on se fait confiance et donc
on a du mal à admettre quand on se
trompe on a du mal à admettre que
peut-être que nos opinions sont basés
sur un processus de raisonnement qui
peut être biaisé et donc maintenant
ajouter à ça le fait qu'on vit
aujourd'hui dans un monde dans lequel il
ya énormément d'informations qui
circulent sur internet avec beaucoup
d'émetteurs et de diffuseurs de
l'information qu'elles soient vraies ou
fausses et n'étant pas armés pour ceux
d'août on va faire confiance aux choses
qu'on lit on va même avoir une des
versions différentes et via le biais de
confirmation le biais de confirmation
c'est le fait qu'on va plus avoir
tendance à aller vers des choses qui
confirme nos croyances que les choses
qui et les infirmes et donc viable par
exemple le biais de confirmation
on va plus avoir tendance à avoir des
faits chacun différents et donc ça c'est
un vrai danger pour la démocratie
parce qu'autant win pour une démocratie
c'est sain d'avoir des opinions qui sont
différents autant c'est dangereux
d'avoir des faits des faits divers
sacré de plus de réalité commune plus de
socle de réalité qui permettent de
progresser
donc aujourd'hui une grande partie de
mon activité consiste à trouver des
manières de cultiver l'habitude du doute
c'est à dire développer l'esprit
critique armes et les gens contre le
flou contre la fausse précision comment
faire pour redonner aux gens l'appétit
de la preuve que ça j'essaye de le faire
sur l'eau shell en l'échelle
individuelle mais j'essaie aussi depuis
depuis quelques années de travail et au
niveau des politiques publiques c'est à
dire sur les des questions d'intérêt
général sur la vaccination sur les ogm
sur ce genre de questions vous allez me
dire que il ya beaucoup de doutes oui
les gens doutent beaucoup doutent des
vaccins doute des ogm doute des
politiques de des versions officielles
doute de la médecine traditionnelle etc
mais le doute quand on parle pas assez
c'est le doute de soi même douter de ses
propres connaissances de ses propres
intuitions de ses propres réponses
automatiques et donc ça aussi c'est
extrêmement importante mais aussi
importantes que les décideurs publics
mettent en place les politiques
publiques doutes de leurs propres biais
donc ça c'est une des choses qu'on fait
mais aussi prendre en compte ces billets
là dans le fonctionnement des politiques
publiques c'est-à-dire intégrés aux
politiques publiques les connaissances
en sciences comportementales pour les
rendre les plus proches possibles du
fonctionnement en fait des citoyens
d'une part et surtout une grande partie
de notre activité consiste à utiliser la
méthode scientifique qui est aujourd'hui
la méthode la plus robuste rooney pour
limiter ces biais pour tester et évaluer
les politiques publiques avant de les
mettre en place à grande échelle
parce que si on ne teste pas les
politiques publiques
on ne sait pas ce qui marche et donc
testé c'est une sorte de posture
d'humilité
donc tout cela nous amène à adopter une
sorte de
d'humilité intellectuelle c'est ce que
c'est ce que j'essaie de de prêcher et
donc pour la thématique de cette soirée
qui est le retour au local dans locale
d'un retour le câble ce que j'entends
c'est retour ce cercle de connaissances
prendre conscience de connaissances
connais pas ce que ça veut pas dire s'en
contenter ça veut juste dire en prendre
conscience pour être dans une posture
d'humilité qui nous permettent de
progresser
pourquoi parce que le plus grand ennemi
de la connaissance n'est pas l'ignorance
les plus grands ennemis du progrès n'est
pas la connaissance mais c'est
l'illusion de connaissances
merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]